i've been emotional
um i think it's my first season i think
it's definitely emotional and especially
when blake's drink runs out he gets very
emotional cranky
the only time blake shelton and ariana
grande having a little fun with e.t and
teasing each other over who's really
getting emotional this season on the
voice and why it's only been emotional
for me yes not for him i don't think
i've cried one time my drink did in your
life
my drink did get empty one time halfway
through an audition it made me sad but
you've actually been emotional for the
right reasons from emotionals i don't
want to get too emotional but i
adore you so over the top oh you look
beautiful
kelly you're a former coach of drashika
so i'm not mistaken oh my goodness
like that was so good
the coaches agree kelly clarkson is
literally the one to watch when it comes
to her reactions kelly like jumps up
like out of her chair and like she can't
ever play anything cool it's wonderful
though it makes people feel so
good about it you know and then they pan
to you and
and what do i have big i don't have a
big reaction do i
no no
you're jaded now yeah and when it comes
to the least reactive coach well blake
doesn't hold back john doesn't even
react to anything by the way no that's
the clearest answer if you said who has
the least reaction to anything
it's john legend
paris let's uh
uh kelly clarkson through her shoes now
a grouper duo has yet to win in 20
seasons of the voice the coaches are
already debating whether one could take
the win this year
[Music]
to make it
better
oh my god i know i've wanted to steal i
actually wanted to steal your duo good
luck oh my god groups and duos they have
a tough time on the show because
you know
the chances of for that one person to
connect with everybody that that's hard
enough not to say that it won't happen
and we haven't gotten close because we
have gotten close but i think that's why
we haven't had a winner yet i just think
this season it's so special and perhaps
perhaps
[Music]